we'll take our fortunes and invest in
the west go west go west oh man I've
been one upgrade the microphone setup on
this block it's not clear enough it's
not focused enough it doesn't have a
wide enough dynamic range from the high
frequencies and the low frequencies to
really get good human voices today my
friend Leo is visiting from Italy he's a
sound engineer he's bringing along the
Zen hyzer mkh four one six it's
basically the industry standard
microphone for recording the human voice
dialogue I want to compare it to all the
microphones we've used here on the
quarter videos and the Sami Nico vlogs I
want to know if it's worth upgrading to
[Music]
I'm now on Isla Mujeres
which is completely different than
central Mexico and I'm down here because
my brother's best friend is celebrating
his wedding
what is this this is an aboveground
cemetery they can't bury him underground
because of sea level right right 100
years old into the other side of the
island for dinner and little did I know
way more real or ass
[Music]
we are in the Playa del media Luna code
right all on this side of the island are
rocks except for this little Cove right
here which is a nice little backdrop for
wetting the flame of love loses nothing
by lighting another flame after a few
hours of testing all the mics we
imported the files and played it back in
audition so we can figure out which one
is the best but remember we're looking
for clarity focus and dynamic range
Jesus Christ and our Road mic that we
have on our DSLR is all the time should
be able to hear some creaking behind me
so we have our sony microphone from our
original camera the fs100 as you can
tell these are not ideal conditions so
we want to try it out here and then in a
good spot okay so this is the vlog
microphones in a controlled environment
our sound room our audio Technium Ike
this is about optimal distance from the
subject this is what these mics sound
like and we have the sennheiser 416 this
is about optimal distance from the
subject this is what these mics sound
like
[Music]
that was the sound test I hope it wasn't
too boring for you but I do want to ask
you for one thing you pick did the
Sennheiser sound better than anything
else or did our current rode mic sound
good enough that we don't need to get a
new mic because I'm really interested in
seeing if I need to upgrade my sound
gear to make this show any better so let
me know down below back to Mexico I
headed back into town
now this graduate Bob stall along the
way Harry just showed us a really cool
hair cable this showed us a really cool
thing I might be behind at the time
google translate this water bottles in
Spanish I take this phone I line it up
to it and boom
it translates it ready
[Music]
oh wow
drinko DeMaio JC every year I'm thanking
go DeMaio which is an American holiday
it's no excuse for shoes we're going
from here you see that light post down
there not all right we're going weather
where they are
[Music]
awake
we went to the wedding rinse it eat on
the other side of town it was really
nice house getting some great shots all
sudden I feel maybe like I just
something's wrong with my stomach not a
big deal brush it off have another drink
I forget about it and then and then
we're at this beach bar finding our own
business and I got to step aside to puke
my brains out
diarrhea suffered by travelers
especially visitors to Mexico I'm puking
my brains out I'm thinking oh maybe I
just drank too much like this is weird
though I don't feel that drunk so yawn I
get back to the room 1 a.m. boat hits me
again yeah I'm having shivers it's a
hyperactive 5 times I had to get up and
to my guts out with of course you know
everything else coming out the other end
until coin and I stumbled to a bodega
this morning to get bunch of water which
I can barely keep down do I feel better
yeah do I need some water
yeah well I want a drink no anyway we're
gonna go to a barbecue
I conveyed to the beach barbecue I still
can't eat well still drill me sounded
upset I ate something and I got up here
got a two hour nap in right here on the
sand
whoo I don't feel like walking off a
cliff anymore
things are looking up
[Music]
about a hat